if you're a fan of The Witcher and
you've already seen the news can the
Netflix fantasy series really survive
without Henry Cavill Liam Hemsworth will
take over the role of geralt from Henry
Cavill in season four for reasons I may
or Maynards have something to do with
the latter's recently revitalized Korea
as a dceu Superman Hemsworth certainly
has the looks and chop support Traders
stoic powerful garibald of Rivia however
caval owns a role so thoroughly that
many fans have been reflexively hitting
the eject button after the recast news
which is a pretty clear important of
Doom for a franchise that's named after
its main character's day job to use an
analogy that befits Cavill every
live-action version of Superman is going
to be compared to Christopher Reeves
sooner or later likewise Hemsworth now
faces the seemingly insurmountable task
of carrying his beloved predecessor
silver wig with adequate Gruff and Grace
recasts like this have been bought off
before just as a James Bond franchise
people want to stay alive let's say
yeah
please stay alive
the difference here is that if Hemsworth
turns out to be a George Lazenby it
seems unlikely that the viewers on
Netflix for that matter will give The
Witcher another chance probably the
biggest thing that favors the witch's
Hemsworth era is the vast wealth of
stories as show has referred to left and
tapped there are still tons of plot
lines that can really grab the Fan's
attention going by Shia cultural
significance alone this means a show is
almost unabound to soften the blow of
recasting by diving head first into the
wild Hunt the show was already revealed
that the wild Hunt plays a role in
things to come season 2 prominently
features volath mare who turns out to be
a dark elf affiliated with the wild Hunt
the hunt itself also makes a brief but
suitably ominous appearance in the
season finale as such it should be just
a matter of time before this crew comes
calling for Siri here's a crucial
question about the show's survival
though when will the wild Hunt start
making moves introducing the other
worldly antagonists could easily keep
the show going for a good few seasons
and given the fact that travel is
leaving after the next season the most
effective time for the wild Hunt's
proper introduction would be in the
season 3 finale this would provide an
irresistible Cliffhanger that could
bring fans back next season caval or no
caval Henry Cavill originally committed
to The Witcher for seven seasons and
since the nilf guardian storyline will
likely swallow a whole bunch of season 3
hours the wild hunts could indeed chill
out for the majority of the Season only
to Makers charge at the optimal moment
for Hemsworth to tag in for season four
however get the timing wrong and there's
a risk that a notable portion of viewers
will clock out with caval like it or not
it seems that season 4 will definitely
be a watershed moment for The Witcher if
the show can manage its sprawling cast
of characters introduce cool enough plot
lines and handle the transition from
Cavill to Hemsworth with Grace it has
conquered a challenge that puts geralt's
worst in Universe enemies to shame and
as effectively as Invincible as long as
Netflix's algorithms smile on it if not
well at least it was fun while it lasted
it The Witcher has all the tools to make
the change work but when the pressure is
mounting and the biggest star the show
is leaving many people might suddenly
have suggestions on how to Tinker with
the premise all put over focus on
certain characters perhaps new
non-cannon characters that decidedly
shouldn't be introduced will be
introduced anyway maybe there will be a
temptation to take unnecessary Liberties
of some storylines from The Source
material or needless shortcuts with
others if the Witcher can't resist
tinkering with what works either to take
attention away from the recasting OR at
an honest attempt to provide fire
support for the new lead the show just
might be in serious trouble